hi folks my name is Alex Sharma I'm a
developer advocate at circle CI and I am
here today to talk to you about
continuous integration which is a
software development practice work
everyone on the engineering team is
continuously integrating these small
code changes back into the codebase
after each change that they're making
there's a suite of tests that runs
automatically that checks the code for
any bugs or errors or anything like that
cool so what does that look like in
practice I've drawn this beautiful flow
chart up here for you step one is you
make a change and this is something
maybe on github you make a future branch
you push it up submit a pull request
that change that I'm talking about here
okay push that up then you run your
tests automatically and that's that's
pretty important the tests need to be
run in a consistent way so that everyone
on your team has full confidence that
they're running the tests in the same
way you don't really have a guarantee
that your machine is the same that is
you know your neighbor's machine that's
that's really hard to to lock down so
those tests are running automatically
somewhere else if it passed right they
pass you're good to go and you can just
keep making changes right if you go
right back around submit another for
requests go a while if the tests fail
you need to make sure it's your
responsibility to fix the code okay fix
the code until your tests pass and then
you can continue developing so it's this
wonderful cycle the idea being that you
want to catch these bugs as soon as you
can right so you're not lingering over a
long period of time so that's what
continuous integration is and next time
we'll talk about why you would be doing
this we'll dig into that next